hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to don't escape for we
just got through the first two nights
and now we need to make sure that berry
doesn't die this is very important why
because the ghost of his dead wife came
to me in my dream and told me very
explicitly don't let my hubby die so I'm
not gonna do that I'm definitely not
gonna do that
I don't want no ghosts after me that's
for damn sure so I'm gonna get
everything that I think I might need put
away the warm stuff I don't think we'll
need that anymore the thermal blanket
the nails I don't think we're gonna need
a rock of course we need that lighter
Kroeber this that this that and this and
then finally probably finally anyway
we're gonna be able to get our wheels no
no no no Kate I don't care we're not
talking we're not talking you you and I
were not talking even though in this
weird universe you've seen me be a
little bit nicer but maybe that's
because I'm not bothering with all my
talking and I'm not arms ensure if I
should be happy about that but at least
you seem to be relatively nice to me
so we need to make there on foot we need
to make our way there on foot if I
actually use proper grammar okay we're
gonna go there straight away that's what
I've been told is important and maybe
there's gonna be a wheel here the city
didn't survive even the first weeks
after the apocalypse hit by earthquakes
it was quickly abandoned only to be
swallowed by sands after the climate
changed I never liked the idea of going
there it was like a massive tombstone
emerging from the wasteland luring
travelers so it would become a grave for
more victims if this was the place we
had to go to and this is the place that
Barry has to wait at okay we're gonna
skip through this
can you stay behind and wait for us hey
Barry could you wait for us by the road
why don't you think it's dangerous to
separate like this yeah usually it is I
just have a bad feeling about this one
can you trust me on that
just wait for us I have no idea why
you're doing this but okay
I'll just wait by the road thanks Barry
no problem just be careful out there
okay alright thanks Barry alright now
Barry guaranteed safety so we need to
overwrite this save just in case I did
something kind of funky and if I did
then that's that'd be bad if all the
places I could have crashed into it had
to be with a handsome well-spoken and
well-meaning man
like myself you know you could have
crash-landed into abandoned camp or a
bunch of cacti but no you got here with
me
lucky anyway long hell huh a little
weird
hopefully Kate doesn't somehow end up on
the other side of this gap this time
okay Kate
now just wait back wait hang on back a
little bit oh ha boots key all right
Cody
oh jeez that was a close one huh that
was real close you all right Cody you
okay
Wow did you see that this holds like
bottomless I was so scared but you saved
me you were actually very brave and you
do the same for me
so what now we're lucky nobody fell here
it looks really deep yes lucky us it
seems you have to go on without me for
now find the location of that base look
for documents or a map of some sort
we'll just meet up later good luck yeah
you go hang out with Barry have fun by
the road or at Cody come on now we're
not gonna be depressed as we go in here
it's so fun it's so fun it's full it's
fun right right Cody it's fun it was
small rock why would I need a friend
friends friends we got rock friends rock
buddies why do I need a rock though I
got a bad feeling about that they're
gonna be
Spidey's in here oh boy what was that I
am scared um okay for a good record like
this second run-through has been a lot
scarier than the other walkthrough
they're actually gonna be something in
the darkness a dead body gives an ID on
his neck okay if I remember there's a
key on this side okay let's just go here
I don't like that I don't like it at all
it gives me the heebie-jeebies
no I don't like it it was probably a
demon in the corner that we didn't see
at first glance all right so if this
probably changed maybe no no no wait Oh
5010 it hasn't changed I have no idea to
negative 22 to be gone done okay perfect
oh I thought that was a note on there
okay all right so it's on now spiders no
spiders okay but we got a silencer
though assassins
yeah probably any internet no no
it's still no porn for me okay leaves on
leave on leave on leave visitation list
of people from world s P for now it all
starts to make sense
Catherine Mayweather yeah so I don't
think that there gonna be anything new
that we need to know but there are some
details that might help us out just in
case there is something new but I don't
think so
the other ones 15 and 40 okay I think
that's still the same okay there's the
location all right cool all right that's
all we need so 15 and 40 I just need to
recycle this to go down where was that
going here okay
I think that was it whew this is what
it's supposed to be alright whatever
Kroeber no no no no no no no no no no
bad David Kahne behave I have a little
bit this no listen you gotta be a yeah
that's what I'm talking about event I
can't fit in there hey Cody
hey Cody then can you go come on chop
chop let's go tada
yeah got ya go good job Cody good job
good job I'm finally gonna be a floppy
disc okay that's the phase control
system
it feels very important so this means
that Barry can help me move the pipe and
that's good thing so once we're able to
climb back up Barry's still alive I
unlock that door and then bought a bingo
bottom on go we're still good
everything's still hunky everything is
still dory and all is Gucci in the world
okay so we don't there's nothing of use
here except opening the door back this
way then we just open this one a BAM and
Babu ski ah it's good to see you two
back Kate told me what happened if you
hadn't warned me to stay how did you
know dreams yes
dreams there might still be something
worth checking out in that building I
think it's safe to go together now Barry
if you say it's important the first Kate
if you get the location yeah I found the
map ba-ba-ba-ba-ba we can go right away
Bob for the storm to pass in our base we
have to stay one more night how about we
stay here then the storm will get to us
here - you've seen weather anomalies
before I'd rather be in our reinforced
base than here in this deathtrap flooded
with sand and acid rain water ah yeah
that's a good point yeah it's a real
good point okay let's uh let's go back
he over here I'm guessing it's another
floppy it's definitely another floppy
Hey
Mary why don't you just stop standing
around or we could all help you know hey
can you help me with this
hey go there she is there she is labeled
member skye have a strange feeling like
deja vu like it's really important for
some reason I think I should keep that
disk oh you know I will all the
necessary preparations have been
completed we are ready to start the
procedure according to calculations
chances of success are about 89% as I
mentioned in our last conversation with
current conditions that will not be able
to get better results and I think this
is a risk we must take at the moment we
do not have much information about the
crystals and we're in the possession of
a very small amount we need more if we
want our expeditions to continue even if
an attempt to synthesize more would end
up in disaster this is more important
than the existence of one world even in
the event of failure we will gain a huge
amount of information that will allow us
to increase the safety of the procedure
in the future
SB 273 8 is expendable the level of
development leaves much to be desired it
is also one of the least profitable
facilities according to instructions
from director from SP 4 you should
immediately evacuate mrs. Stanford has a
list of employees who should be informed
about the evacuation if it is an actual
necessity interesting is there another
like article in here I remember seeing
something but a stack of papers hurry up
backpack is full I have to put something
down first okay let's drop this for a
second I remember seeing this patient
reasonably adjoined oh yeah we already
there's the thing that's the thing in
the dream that's the thing in the dream
so why do I have to rocks
I don't know whatever alright guys we're
good let's get out of here we got to get
gone I don't think having that piece of
paper is gonna be important to me so
it's gonna keep bums in the only thing
important is the floppy disks I think
anyway right so that's all we needed
from here so now we got to walk back so
I bet we're probably gonna get a tire
right around there but just in case
because this is a lot of walk and then
we're gonna have to do I'd rather not
walk more than we need to we're gonna
pop by right here we're gonna save and
then we're gonna go but I'm gonna go
straight there unless I need to actually
I'm gonna drop stuff off first that
would be smart because I'm a smart I'm a
big smart I am smart alright let's go up
here yeah yeah yeah let's check around
back first I don't know why this whoa
that tree what the [ __ ] tree hello I'm
the treat hell yeah I love climbing
trees
whoa well this was kind of pointless but
at the same time I do like it don't know
why I went up there but hey
five minutes well-spent my book let's
see about this is it another puzzle or
is it the same puzzle I see scratches
there's some visible scratches on the
floor as if something was pushed back
and forth repeatedly painting depicts
wolf or large dog I think I've seen this
somewhere before one of the antlers is
skewed I can't reach it do I have what
it takes to reach it this seems long
enough to be able to push the lever
there's a loud clunk there we go okay it
was a revolver and the safe there's
still something there there was a box of
rifle ammo there's one more box inside
there was revolver ammo and the safe the
safe is empty let me just over here
well wooden boards okay that's good can
of wood sealer a broom stick I don't see
any wheel where am I gonna get it with
weight back into the restaurant the
restaurant would have had it right the
restaurant would have had it I think
okay so I'm gonna pick up the the
whiskey just in case I'll put here kid
put some hair on your chest here you go
okay can you guys guys get out of the
way so I can grab that wood sealer
please thank you look in the can is dry
and useless something has been covered
with it though as the lid was left open
weird
okay wooden boards great I guess um I
don't know what those would be for but
I'm willing to bet and I might be
willing to load up the save this is why
I save because I bet in the restaurant
in the back area is gonna be a tire and
if I can get oh whoa whoa whoa whoa hold
it well who are you hands in the air now
relax guys we're just hands in the air
now alright alright there okay Kate
would you please don't shoot us we're
innocent
it's okay Cody they're not gonna shoot
us you're soldiers you wear uniforms
where's your decency ambushing peaceful
travelers like a bunch of thugs sir
you're not being ambushed we're just
holding guard here who are you my name
is mark and this is Kate and alright
save it you can explain everything to
the Sarge
our ID list keep it civilized I'm very
much in favor of that let's start with
this who are you and what are you doing
here we're a family maybe we should
maybe that's not a bad idea
I better not start with a lie Kate
wouldn't go along with
we're just travelers looking for
supplies through looters that's a harsh
word we're just trying to survive my
name is Mark and this is Kate that's
Cody hello and that's Barry mhm and
you're just looking for supplies
yes can I ask you the same question
sergeant first class Franklin Mick
Willis and this is my squad - mark
Stephen Paul so you're with the army we
are the army all that's left of it it
would appear there is no more government
there's no more HQ we are on our own
you're still wearing uniform sir that's
what keeps us together son what are you
gonna do with us now nothing at ease
guys back to your posts all right sorry
about that you never know these days
it's good to meet a friendly face for
once what happened to him
who Steve we were attacked a small group
of bandits nothing we couldn't handle
but Steve was wounded and it's not doing
well we don't have anything to treat him
with I was hoping we'd find something
here but no luck what do you need
exactly some bandages and something to
disinfect his wounds like alcohol and he
oh what's your plan Sarge
where did whiz this is a final stop
before we attempt to take on the desert
lies beyond this place I guess you're
traveling in the same direction you
could join us if you want have you seen
any interesting places worth exploring
we're looking for things too fortified
our hideout mm-hmm there's a
construction site south of here my boys
saw when they scouted the area but we're
not sure what's there maybe you'll find
something useful there here let me mark
it on your map actually we're going east
east that's terrible idea we just came
from there escaping a dreadful storm is
Harrell I'm telling you thunderstorms
like you've never seen before the rain
is acidic it burns the skin trust me you
don't want to go east not today at least
you have any ideas on how we can survive
the storm damn it son why are you so
stubborn if you have to stay dig some
ditches around your hideout to lead the
water away also maybe talk to Paul he's
our technician and I know he has some
scientific instruments that might help
you but don't expect our help for
nothing in return we have all needs the
moon is falling on our heads
yeah Wow I didn't notice maybe I was too
busy trying to look after myself and my
squad because the damn moon
loaded and is falling on us what I meant
was it is going to crash into Earth like
really soon good good it's all gonna end
it has to this whole nightmare let me
tell you a story okay sure our squad was
helping with evacuation we were on a
chopper hovering above a football
stadium where people had gathered is the
same story suddenly BAM another
earthquake and everything went to hell
literally the ground split open bursting
out red flames do you know the Bible non
expert I wasn't a religious man but
after seeing all this after seeing the
whole stadium of people being swallowed
by Hell itself in one chomp it was then
that I realized there is no hope nothing
is gonna end well
this is Judgment Day the final chapter
of mankind we have a spaceship ok I
think this is all the same come with us
that's a good point don't you want to
come with us
David word please what is the Cape we
can't just offer a ride to everyone we
meet toady and Barry I get it there with
us but we can't take more hitchhikers we
don't know what condition the ship is in
how much fuel there will be how much air
reserves there might be a strict weight
limits ok I wouldn't want to go anyway
but the world is doomed I've come to
terms with that any men they have the
right to decide for themselves right
right but we're a team a squad that
keeps together no matter what why don't
you ask them yourself right now I'm
asking you okay so here's my answer
good luck with your plan I mean it but
we're staying sorry scared you will head
off soon after the sunset until then if
you need anything just ask
ok that's awfully nice now let me see if
there's a tire somewhere around here can
magazine this probably same magazine yep
ok same magazine there there's a closet
door here come on where's the tire
where's the tire hmm where does the tire
did I miss a tire or something is there
a tire somewhere around here that I have
not seen because I swear there's
supposed to be a tire I swear
oh hi Paul are you doing hi David eh I'm
Paul I'm the team's main engineer
engineer huh nice to meet you is there
anything you need um we want to survive
that storm why don't you just come with
us and avoid the whole thing there's no
time escaping the storm means we lose
too much of tomorrow to travel back if I
were you I'd make sure the house you're
staying at has lightning rod on the roof
and if it doesn't
make one you have anything we laugh
something they called storm cases
experimental devices created by SideReel
plexus have to know lucky guess anyway
this technology actually repels
thunderstorms can we have them well I'm
not sure come on you're not staying here
for the storm so you don't really need
them yeah but why she that you have them
because we want them you know what prove
me you actually deserve our help David
why don't we just calm down kay please
we'll think of something I know what
we'll think of do you want to come with
us negative can you take all of us with
you probably not then as I said negative
we're team a remarkably noble and stupid
and not so stupid bye see you I don't
need to ask all of them because I have a
funny feeling I know what the answer is
there's a construction site over there
maybe they have a tire and let me save
first this was good to come back to and
see first but I'm thinking if there was
ever a place to have a tire it might be
a good source is crazy cuz like it's the
same map and lab but it's an entirely
new experience let's see if there's any
there's no one snip sniping so we're
good there no bandits okay a folded tarp
that's good um let me go ahead and put
down these stupid pieces of paper I
don't think I'm gonna need them I don't
want to go back to put things up just
yet the magazine is probably the same
aliens huh no David no aliens it's for
not far from the truth oh-ho yeah uh-huh
okay concrete slabs a generator can't
reach that it's big and heavy it's in
the way spool of wire
it's stuck so interesting okay I don't
see a tire but maybe there'll be a tire
underneath that when I lift it up it's
always a possibility
alright so what does the generator need
does it need gas it's out of fuel okay
so all it needs is gas let's go up and
actually let's let's go get gas first
because if we don't have gas we're not
gonna there's no point in wasting five
minutes to climb I don't think I have
that I do I do have the gas this is
wasting a lot of time on travel I can
see how this second round you got to be
really careful about this [ __ ] but uh
you know I think this is okay
cuz I'm gonna get a tire cuz if we go
back oh man I wish unless there was some
time maybe from a car wait a minute am I
an idiot
don't answer that I have to check
something
all right so that was just to go over
there and look real quick but I was just
wondering if there was a tire there I
don't think there was so I think um okay
so I'm gonna go back here I'm gonna go
get gas first save a little bit of time
cuz it's just 10 minutes from here be a
little more efficient about this save a
little time time saved is time earned is
time you time say you save time to save
lives you save lives when you're saving
time when you save time look at the
clock what do you have time so let's
just get this time and get this gas and
put it in the generators ass we're gonna
put this in here I fueled up the
generator now I just have to start it
start that let's climb up the crane
let's box of cables some electrical
cables inside controls okay so we're
gonna go this way
yeah okay okay so we're gonna raise up
we're gonna open the clamps we're gonna
move it over this way we're gonna pull
it down gonna close it we're gonna lift
her up we're gonna move her I've already
lifted what I wanted I'm done you're
just gonna let it hang up in the air oh
okay alright then I guess that's fine
yeah well don't mind me I'm just gonna
walk under this okay yeah I forgot to
put these down that's right yeah
this feels safe I feel good about this I
feel real good about that that's fine no
tire are still no tire but that's okay
cuz tires are for liars and I am no liar
what about this truck yeah no okay
dammit where's that goddamn tie here
maybe I'm an idiot am I an idiot can we
take that tire oh oh I could have had it
at any moment
god I'm well I'll come pick this up on
the way back I'm so dumb I've wasted so
much time I could've had oh my god I've
wasted so much time oh no what have I
done
Oh what have I done what have I done I
am so stupid
oh I'm so I left it in the car Oh God
alright so we're gonna bring the car
back to Barry's garage so that we can
get it more fuel-efficient because
that's important I am so dumb at any
moment I could have had this car I
forgot that tires are on cars everywhere
and it's just so convenient the way that
an apocalypse can provide so many tires
Barry hey can you use your technical
know-how on this truck of mine by the
way your wife loved you Nega love you of
course you didn't and I loved her but
why on earth would you bring that up now
just I don't know I don't think she
blames you for anything that happened I
don't want to talk about David we have
things to do all right I like fixing up
this car fuel injectors might be
something wrong can you take a look at
the engine
yeah sure there we go there all right I
can't believe I'm an idiot but it's fine
cuz we're gonna survive I am crumpled I
am grump polishes roof covered and
leaves solar panels yeah that probably
how they kept the lights on at night
solar panels don't work in that come on
David don't be stupid they store the
power during the day anyway I was joking
yeah I doubt they collect anything well
I could climb the roof using the porch
railing but I need something to help
remove those leaves can I climb too no
there's a broom over here oh wait I
forgot I haven't even been here yet we
could oh yeah maybe it'd be better to
survive here because only two windows I
only have two sets of nails maybe be
better oh well now we got power okay
cool
ah great actually go ahead and push
that and I got a look at this first
apparently because I'm I'm stupid
okay safe is empty you can take these
wood panels I don't know what we're
gonna do with it and this whiskey okay
so then I still can't do anything with
the can of wood sealer liquids dry and
useless something been covered with
though as the lid was left open so I
think that that means that the the
entire place has been covered with wood
sealer which is good I think that's
gonna help a lot okay so I still don't
know if there's enough time left in the
today to prep everything because we'd
still have to dig a trench and all that
jazz we'd still have to make all that
stuff I gotta go grab the bandages out
of this place yeah there's too many
holes in this building for us to
realistically stay here so van Dee's is
an alcohol that should be good enough um
the wood panels I mean they're they're
not gonna help as much as plastic wrap I
doubt plastic wrap would what would melt
more wood or plastic I mean it depends
on the type of plastic some plastic is
nonreactive to assets but maybe you and
melt easier I'm not sure blankets would
fall apart I mean maybe the woods
actually a better choice but plastic
could maintain like a waterproof seal
which might be more important no it just
depends on the type of plastic I guess
all right let's get back to the
restaurant four hours and 32 minutes
that's not a lot of time okay how about
we give we soak this Molotov cocktail
how about we don't do that and it should
help yeah thanks and the whiskey I guess
this could be used to disinfect the
wound
whoa wait that'd be a waste to find
whiskey oh come on you can have the rest
of it that's it we can now properly menu
wound Steve can you help Kate why
because I'm a girl it automatically
means I'm a nurse it's okay I'll do it
uh what do you want you always this
friendly only with bullet holes ma'am
how do you feel now better thanks oh
yeah oh now I just got to talk to the
dude in the back hey I helped your buddy
what's with those storm catchers well
since you helped Steve I'm out feel
obligated to help you in return so here
they are backpacks full oh [ __ ] how do
you use them okay so there are three
caches in a set each of them has to be
mounted in a hot spot the higher the
better each also has needs electricity
to function in order to make them work
you have to place them all within a few
miles of each other
try forming a triangle around your high
okay would you put a storm catcher on
the hamburger pylon outside this
restaurant it's not very high but
nothing else but a desert around I guess
it would be fine it should also be
electrical cables here you just need to
power it I guess it's good spot can you
help us put storm catchers I don't know
ask Sarge if that's possible okay all
right so a triangle now that's
fascinating if I didn't have the truck
I'd never be able to do that so if I'm
staying
I guess construction site yeah that
would work then I would stay at the
house uh I guess yeah all right I don't
know how much time I have to do this but
I'm gonna try my best okay we're gonna
keep the wood panels in here grab the
last storm catcher wire we have wire all
right this is starting to get to the
point where I don't know what's going on
let's ask him if it's possible volcanoes
storm catcher things is he told me about
those yes so I'm supposed to install
them somewhere else high above ground
form a triangle around our base sounds
like a plan to me if Paul says you to
work this restaurant pylons sign is very
high but it's surrounded by mostly empty
space it should be sufficient according
to Paul could you help us get it up
there we don't have a ladder or anything
like that
mmm how about we trade what do you have
in mind we're low on ammo when our guns
are in critical condition bring me a
firearm some bullets and I can order my
men to install this thing out for you we
have a deal yeah okay how about revolver
this revolver should do it's in perfect
condition where did you find it and my
sources like my pockets and revolve
around this ammo will do all right can
you now help so what's our deal you've
done your part
just give me the storm catcher and we'll
put it on top of the restaurant side
yeah sure
okay okay oh my boys put on the pylon
we'll also power the pylon so the storm
Kitchel actually works thanks Sarge no
problem we'll remember you still have to
install two more storm caches to form a
triangle around your base all right good
to know I don't think there was anything
else here that I could take they've
grabbed all the food so there is like
oil and rat poison in here but I don't
even know if these are useful anymore
like what am I gonna do with oil or rat
poison okay so the obvious thing that
needs to happen is I need to put the
other one here that's
definite uh yeah definitely definitive
ok so put this up here somewhere
whoa ouch okay um
all right don't make me look dumb here
don't make me look dumb okay so clearly
I'm supposed to do something about that
crane but I don't think I have what I
need to do it yet I oh [ __ ] that's not
the right one oh [ __ ] is this really the
last time I saved oh [ __ ] is that really
the last time I saved Wow oh my god are
you kidding me
no oh [ __ ] really oh [ __ ] oh oh [ __ ]
okay well [ __ ]
tits how much time did I waste all of it
oh my god oh that's the worst thing oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay [ __ ] I've I've now run
completely out of time I've really
goofed this day up um okay all right
that's fine it's all good don't worry
because I know what I'm doing okay so
there is a plug here I'm wondering if I
can throw it out the window and if it's
long enough to run it out the tree it's
gotta be right it has to be right I mean
that's the only thing that would make
sense right yeah okay it is long enough
you take this and take it up the tree
okay so let's put the cord here and but
donkus it's plugged in and working or at
least it's glowing which is good enough
in my book for working so that's all set
and ready to go definitely good to leave
an extension cord like that out in the
storm now we just need to figure out how
to get the one on the other place I
don't think there's enough time but you
know I'm just gonna try my best here Oh
[Music]
oh oh oh I was so dumb I'm so dumb I'm
so dumb I I'm so dumb I still may not
have enough time but I'm so dumb do you
turn it off first and then you plug it
in I'm so dumb
I'm so dumb they turbek oh my god I'm so
incredibly stupid Wow
I am unbelievable for the life of me
it's always the simplest things that
like throw me because I think to my
brain is too smart I think of all the
complex outside-of-the-box ways to solve
it too intelligent that's my problem I
definitely don't think that there's
enough time because the aku has I've
gotta like dig a trench and then I've
got like board up the windows and then
there are just leaks everywhere in the
house that who knows how that's gonna be
solved so yeah good luck to me in that
endeavor uh but you know it's whatever
it's all good you know
you know man it's all good so let's get
to digging let's let's dig let's dig REO
all right 90 minutes you know that's a
lot of time oh we are out of time aren't
we
how much time we got 1 hour and 11
minutes all right cool let's see what
happens baby definitely gonna work we're
gonna be fine all is gonna be good
everything's gonna be great everything's
good [ __ ] okay we definitely got a cover
of the chimney that's a number one
definite and a lightning rod and I'm
gonna make a lightning rod out of what
do I have to make a lightning rod and
god this is awful try to cover it from
the outside how am I gonna do that maybe
from up here I should cover both let me
see if I maybe this flag will do - I
don't know
not it won't work this is not gonna work
we don't have enough time I I just don't
think there's enough time to do all the
things that need to be done 16 minutes
great that's good okay cool
put the tarp over it it covers most of
the hole that wouldn't work oh why why
wouldn't it work maybe I could put the
dead bird back
let me try what's it what's the harm
what's the arm that could happen put the
dead bird back in it definitely closed
the hatch but I'm thinking that if we
put the dead bird back I don't think so
uh-huh okay all right how about crowbar
all right how about wire oh whoa lead it
to the ground yeah there we go I've
installed a lightning rod yeah maybe I
shouldn't stand so close to that thirty
minutes
[ __ ] yeah we're dead we're dead I can't
put the bird back in there this
lightning rod will protect us from the
well yeah what about that chimney maybe
chimneys just aren't supposed to work
like that maybe chimneys naturally don't
let things in like that look out and
Amna expert that's covered by a tarp
good enough it's getting real stormy out
here wooden board maybe plastic wrap
would be better I hate to save here
because I know it's not gonna work but
you know with 30 minutes left it's not
gonna do what I want it to do I think
the plastic wrap is gonna be better than
the wood paneling unless it'll just melt
I don't know man maybe not let's try the
wood let's see which I I don't know I
only got enough for two of these so what
does it matter anyway 23 minutes well
that's not enough time that's not enough
time at all wooden board 23 minutes well
[ __ ] it's gonna take a bit more time
because the frame is worn yet yes sure
all right I guess this is it it's
probably not gonna work
cuz I've bet I forgot something but you
know I've got we've got 10 minutes 10
minutes left 10 big honkin minutes what
about the flag and I still put that
there just in case you never know there
we go that feels good that feels safe
anybody want rat poison to drink before
we die all right whatever let's do it
take something from your inventory I
don't know man what would what would
even be helpful a water sprayer Oh water
sprayer perfect love it oh I can't use
the water sprayer damn
a blankie just to keep me warm at night
all right wrench fine
yes day ended black clouds pushed by
winds from the east covered its sky
casting dark shadows below loud thunder
was sounding all around preceded by a
sudden and sharp flashes of light with
them the first raindrops fell on the
wastelands it's not the life-giving
water the dry land had been thirsty for
it was saturated with burning acid as if
the earth decided to clean its surface
of life before the moon did you put a
storm catcher on the crane and the
Qataris decide it's special magnetic
field push some of the clouds away you
put a storm catcher in the tree five
percent five percent all three storm
catchers were placed and functional the
form triangle filling 20 percent nice
dug ditches driving away some of the
water 15 percent you secure the
helicopter hold covering with a tarp ten
percent close the roof hatch good idea
is stop ten percent of the water
man improvised lightning rod good call
lowered threat by twenty percent you
close the front door stop some water
closed eyes stop some water where was
nailed to frame seven prints what with
ten minutes left
Wow Oh the roof was already leaking but
not much rainwater managed to pour
inside you were safe you survived to see
another wait no that's not perfect wait
wait wait wait alright hold on its hold
on a second here that wasn't perfect hey
wait a minute
hey wait a minute I thought it was
perfect alright so I'm gonna just
everybody hold on I'll be back in just a
bit because I have to take care of some
stuff okay I'm back in the house and
I've got now 4 hours and 29 minutes I've
already dug the ditch outside so I'm in
pretty good shape I think this will work
and the only difference is boarding up
all the windows I don't know I'm not
sure but I'll do my best I'll do my very
best
oh yeah that would help fix the tarp to
the roof of the duct tape that makes
more sense now the tarp is held in place
nicely ah that would make a lot of sense
close the hatch alright so that's now
duct tape there that's that makes a lot
more sense okay so let's put boards on
all this [ __ ] and maybe duct tape is
better because it'd be like more a
watertight seal I mean not that it's
gonna be a watertight seal but you know
you know
it is okay there's enough time there's
enough time still so I gotta get the
last board and then that should be all
she wrote for that one this has been
like an entirely new adventure because
I've had no idea how to tackle all this
and sold sealed boards in all the
windows yes sealed boards sealed boards
that's very specific wording and I think
that's important so now I think we're
gonna get a perfect right right 5:30
time for bed let's do this trusty knife
Crane 5 percent 5 percent 5 percent
triangulation 20 percent ditches 15
percent secure duct tape 20 percent
closer fast 10 percent lighting rod 20
percent Oh didn't even need the board's
you ended up completely dry not even
shaken by the strong winds untouched by
loud thunderstorms and burning acid this
meant some well-deserved sleep you
prepared your ID out perfectly and it
paid off not only did you survive but
you also managed to have some good rest
5 kilograms permanent carry weight and
bada-bing thought of it we've got it
and this time what's happening is it the
end of oiled Wow yeah it's not good yeah
that's no good that's why they call not
good so it is today is it yep
I've seen it all right it's time but
unfortunately this went on way longer
than I thought it was gonna so I
actually don't have time to finish it in
this episode but in the next episode we
definitively will finito this maybe
unless we gotta go around the block
again and then we'll see what happens
when we get there but thank you
everybody so much for watching
get ready to discover the ultimate
ending the true ending or the bad ending
or the good ending or whatever ending it
is in the next video thank you everybody
so much and as always I will see you in
the next video bye I didn't live in
Norfolk edge
[Music]